(ethereal vibratory music)
- [Dean] The glass armonica,
really had this effect
on people who heard it.
I mean, they were saying
it was the most beautiful
sound they'd ever heard.
And there were a lot of beautiful sounds
in the 18th century.
But you know, there
was something different
in the sound of the armonica.
I wanted to give people
that come to Williamsburg
an experience that they
wouldn't get anywhere else.
(twangy music)
- [Chris] I'm Chris Funk.
I'm a musician in a band
called The Decemberists,
and I'm on a journey looking
for the most surprising
and extraordinary people in music.
My next stop takes me to
Williamsburg, Virginia.
There, I will meet one
of the last true masters
of an enchanting instrument,
forgotten by time.
(ethereal vibratory music)
I've traveled to Virginia
and stepped back into history,
to meet a musician who's perfected
a rather unusual medium, glass.
- My name is Dean Shostak,
here in Williamsberg, where I live.
And I play the glass harmonica,
but I also play a number of
other glass instruments, too,
like this Cristal baschet.
- [Chris] Dean has spent years mastering
the skills necessary to play this family
of glass instruments,
all of which originated
with the glass armonica,
an instrument with a
very unexpected creator.
(banjo playing)
(ethereal vibratory music)
- [Dean] The glass armonica was invented
by Benjamin Franklin in 1761.
He had seen somebody
play on the wine glasses
in a concert, and he got the idea
that he could actually use glass
in an entirely different way.
You could actually make them rotate
with a fly wheel you're
working with your foot.
And with wet fingers,
you could play it very
much like a keyboard.
(laughing)
- Almost had it.
(enchanting music)
Obviously, you don't tune this instrument.
- No, that's the one nice thing,
everybody has to tune to me.
First thing you need to do is
get your hands really clean.
And that takes a high calcium content
in the water, which they happen to have
here at this theater.
So, I've got these jugs; I literally
actually bring the water from the theater
back to my house,
to have the same water to
play with all the time.
The skin absorbs moisture,
and so you really want your hands
to start wrinkling up a little bit, too.
The condition of the skin on your fingers
is really what produces the sounds.
(ethereal vibratory music)
- [Chris] And those
mesmerizing sounds produced
by skin on glass are not limited
to the glass armonica
or the Cristal baschet.
The technique has led to some
truly bizarre instruments.
(trumpeting)
Wow.
(hornlike vibrating)
- [Dean] I've heard the
argument made that, you know,
we've gone as far as we can
with acoustic instruments.
(trumpeting)
If you think about glass music
as a still unexplored musical frontier,
it's pretty exciting to think
what instruments we could try in glass.
You know, but we don't know until
we make these instruments
what they're gonna be like.
(ethereal vibratory music)
I think we should know
about the glass armonica,
because it's truly the
first American instrument,
you know, aside from the Native American
instruments already here.
I absolutely had to
teach myself how to play.
My only sources were
reading what Franklin wrote
and these other guys back in the time.
It is new every day.
Every time I sit down
and play the armonica,
it is a fresh experience
and a challenge each time.
(ethereal vibratory music)